La policía, ante una comunidad en luto, respondió con el uso de la fuerza
para infundir miedo:
a una fuerza militarizada,
al encarcelamiento,
a las multas.
La prensa incluso trató de provocar que nos temiéramos unos a otros
por la forma de presentar la historia.
Y este tipo de cosas ya había resultado antes.
Pero como dije, esta vez fue diferente.
La muerte de Michael Brown y la forma en que trataron a la comunidad
desató una ola de protestas en Ferguson, St. Louis y en sus alrededores.
Cuando salí a esas protestas cerca del cuarto o quinto día,
no fue por valentía.
Fue por culpa.
Como ven, soy negro.
No sé si lo notaron.
(Risas)
Pero no podía quedarme en St. Louis, a solo unos minutos de Ferguson,
y no ir a ver.
Así que decidí ir a echarle un vistazo.
Cundo llegué allá,
encontré algo sorprendente.
Percibí enojo, mucho enojo.
Pero lo que más encontré fue amor.
Personas con amor a sí mismos.
Amor por su comunidad.
Y fue hermoso,
hasta que llegó la policía.
Entones intervino una nueva emoción en la conversación:
el miedo.
Ahora, no voy a mentir,
cuando vi los vehículos blindados,
y todo ese equipo,
y todas esas armas,
y todos esos efectivos,
estaba aterrado,
en lo personal.
Y cuando miré a la multitud,
vi a muchas personas a las que les sucedía lo mismo.
Pero también vi gente que tenía algo más en su interior.
Y eso era valentía.
Esas personas gritaban,
y se desgañitaban,
y no tenían intenciones de retroceder ante la policía.
Estaban más allá de ese punto.
Y entonces sentí que algo cambiaba en mí también,
y comencé a gritar a voz en cuello
y me di cuenta que todos a mi alrededor estaban haciendo lo mismo.
Y fue una sensación única.
Así que decidí que quería hacer algo más.
Fui a mi casa y pensé, soy un artista, produzco material.
Así que comencé a hacer cosas especialmente para la protesta,
cosas que fueran armas en una guerra espiritual,
cosas que le dieran una voz a la gente
y que les dieran fortaleza para enfrentar el camino por recorrer.
Hice un proyecto en el que tomé fotos de las manos de los manifestantes
y las puse por todos los recubrimientos de los edificios
y las tiendas en la comunidad.
Mi meta era crear consciencia y levantar la moral.
Y creo que por lo menos por un momento,
eso fue exactamente lo que hice.
Luego pensé, quiero divulgar las historias de estas personas
en las que veía tanta valentía en esos momentos.
Y junto con mi amiga,
cineasta y socia, Sabaah Folayan,
eso fue exactamente lo que hicimos con nuestro documental
"Whose Streets?" (¿De quién son las calles?)
Me transformé en una especie de conductor
de toda esa valentía que me fue dada.
Y creo que esa es una parte de nuestra labor como artistas.
Pienso que debemos comunicar valentía a través del trabajo que hacemos.
Y pienso que somos el muro entre las personas normales
y aquellos que usan su poder para difundir el miedo y el odio,
especialmente en tiempos como estos.
Así que les pregunto.
A todos los activistas y agitadores,
conocidos como líderes del pensamiento.
¿Qué van a hacer
con los dones que se les han dado
para liberarnos del miedo que nos ata cada día?
Porque, ¿saben?, estoy atemorizado todos los días.
No puedo recordar un momento en el que no haya sido así.
Pero cuando me di cuenta de que ese miedo no estaba ahí para inmovilizarme,
sino para protegerme,
y cuando me di cuenta de cómo usar ese miedo,
encontré mi poder.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)